antoine les moscovites sont ils prêts
pour ce confinement
alors oui cela fait plusieurs jours
qu'il se prépare en tout cas sans
compter que la population russe suit de
très près l'évolution de la situation en
europe
c'est donc à moscou que les mesures sont
les plus strictes ou un confinement de
la population était adoptée depuis ce
matin télétravail généralisée distances
sociales d'au moins un mètre cinquante
et bien sûr interdiction de quitter le
domicile mises à part quelques
exceptions comme à la pharmacie ou au
magasin le plus proche
le président russe s'est d'ailleurs
exprimé aujourd'hui pour encourager la
population pour lui dire que cette
mesure est juste et nécessaire et qu'il
est donc important de la respectée et
écoutée et mais il est très important
actuellement qu'il ya opérations entre
les structures locales régionales et
fédérales faux seins qu'elle travaille
de manière cohérente et préventives
longue et il ne faut pas se laisser
aller à la présomption mais agir dans le
calme et l'assurance
il faut aussi que les gens soient
toujours informé objectif derrière de
l'évolution de la situation et des
mesures prises et c'est la meilleure
réponse aux provocations ligne ragot
stupide et spéculations malveillantes
hadj ahmed ressam oui aux représentants
de gamme les niveaux du pouvoir est dans
la mire et n'est donc à bruxelles l'echo
armes et rixheim phcie rooney nous
devons agir de façon raisonnable et
professionnels cette approche nous a
aidés à gagner du temps et à limiter la
propagation explosive du coroner russe
oui ces dernières semaines car elle est
une fierté de deux chenilles et si les
encouragements ne suffise pas le
gouvernement établit tout un barracuda
mort des amants qui commence à partir de
15 mille roubles soit à peu près 170
euros
c'est donc tout un lot de mesures qui
ressemble au final de plus en plus à la
situation actuellement en vigueur en
france
alors que le nombre de contaminations en
russie a atteint 1834 cas pour 10 morts
antoine vladimir poutine doit être
également parlé avec donald trump art
téléphone dans la journée qu'elle
dossier les deux hommes vont ils aborder
mais bien un appel téléphonique qui
devrait largement être consacré aux
cours actuels du pétrole qui se trouve
au plus bas depuis 17 ans le secteur du
pétrole de schiste américain souffre de
l'effondrement des cours et donald trump
souhaite trouver avec vladimir poutine
une solution pour faire repartir les
prix à la hausse
le président américain s'attend à ce que
son homologue russe demande en échange
d'un allègement des sanctions
occidentales qui pèsent très lourd sur
l'économie russe
avec un baril de brent autour des 20
dollars à l'heure actuelle la situation
devient délicate pour tous les pays
producteurs de pétrole même si avec ses
réserves
la russie estime être armé pour tenir
sur la durée
merci antoine claireaux en direct de
moscou en russie